For our purposes,
we won't have to work with the most
general satisfiability problem.
Rather, we can restrict ourselves to
a simpler case, where the boolean
formula has a particular structure
called, conjunctive normal form, or CNF.
Like this one here.
First, consider the operators.
The v indicates a logical or.
The wedge indicates a logical and.
And the bar over top of one of
the variables indicates logical not.
For one of these formulas we need to
define a collection of variables, x, y,
and z, in this example.
And these variables appear
in the formula as literals.
A literal can be either a variable,
or the variables negation.
For example this x or this y bar, etc.
At the next higher
level we have clauses,
which are disjunctions of literals.
You could also say
logical ors of literals.
One clause is what lies in
between a pair of parenthesis.
And finally,
we have the formula as a whole,
which is a conjunction of clauses.
That is to say,
all the clauses get anded together.
Thus this whole formula is
in conjunctive normal form.
In general, there can be more than
two clauses that get anded together.
That covers the terms we'll use for
the structure of a CNF formula.
As for satisfiability itself.
We say that a boolean
formula is satisfiable
if there is a truth assignment for
the formula.
A way of assigning variables true and
false such that the formula
evaluates to true.
The CNF satisfiability problem is,
given a CNF formula, determine if that
formula has a satisfying assignment.
Clearly this formula is in NP.
Since given any truth assignment,
it takes time, polynomial, and
the number of literals
to evaluate the formula.
Thus we've accomplished the first part
of showing that satisfiability is
NP complete.
The other part,
showing that every problem in the NP is
polynomial time reducible to it,
will be considerably more difficult.